على بعد كيلومترات من الكريم الحق هجوم
اوكراني بالمسيرات استهدف موسكو اضرارا في
مبنى يقع في حي اعمال مركزي
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه قالت انها احبطت
هجمات اوكرانيه باربع طائرات مسيره
استهدفت العاصمه ومنطقه بريان جنوب البلاد
مما ادى لاغلاق مؤقت للمطارات سكان الحي
المتضرر عبروا عن معاناتهم وهم يواجهون
خطر الانفجارات لليوم السادس على التوالي
اصابه الطائره ذلك المنزل وشاهدنا الشظائر
المتطايره
كل شيء على ما يرام سنعيش اين يجب ان نذهب
تم اسقاط طائره بدون طيار في الساعه
الثانيه والنصف لم ننام طوال الليل
نحن الروس لا نخاف من اي شيء كل شيء على
ما يرام ما الذي يجب ان نخاف منه ياتي
الهجوم الاخير على موسكو بعد ساعات على
اعلان سلطات الاوكرانيه عن قصر المدفعي
روسي استهدف قريتين قرب مدينه ليمان في
شرق اوكرانيا مما اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه
اشخاص واصابه اثنين بجروح
تكثيف الهجمات المتبادله بين البلدين اسفر
ايضا عن مقتل ثلاثه مدنيين في ضربه جويه
اوكرانيه على مصحه في قريه لافيب بالجورود
من جهتها هجمت روسيا بطائرات مسيره مدينه
اوديسا في جنوب اوكرانيا ومناطق على نهر
الدانوب مما تسبب في اندلاع حرائق في
مستودعات الحبوب